[Music]
they're Jewish see my mother
hold there do I see my father
oh they're do they call to me oh they're
do they call to me
oh they're do they call to me
that Bo's a little big for you isn't it
my mother made me said I'd go into it
[Music]
find your way home
you are free we're taking your asses to
the highest peak in the realms ashes it
was our last wish
well must we go to a realm beyond your
own there's only one peso can get you
and you need to go they call me
Mamiya smartest man alive first you need
to cut off my head wait what thanks you
get you got a handle or special I know
you're a god not of this room but
there's no mistaking it he doesn't know
does he about your true nature or his
own the longer you wait the more damage
you do he will resent you and you may
lose him forever there are consequences
to killing a guard
[Music]
power of this weapon any weapon comes
from here would only win tempered by
this is the self control of the one who
wields it
[Music]
where are your health this is no
ordinary illness the boy is true nature
your true nature fights within him
[Music]
so amina like you know we are not met we
are more than that
[Music]
the responsibility is far greater
[Music]
[Music]
can you kill something that big
[Music]
you
you